[Music]
even the oldest of places can be seen
through new eyes
Quebec City brings to mind European vibe
history and old architecture this city
is all about 400 years old actually
so just wandering each neighborhood is
an experience in itself after the long
cold winters summer is the season of
celebration everyone's out eating
drinking Union soaking up the Sun the
city is right on the water so of course
we wanted to get out and play in it even
in this old city we were down to try
something new
[Music]
maybe not only successfully
[Music]
even when you're eating you can have an
adventure you can eat world-class
cuisine in a restaurant the size of
someone's kitchen the restaurants is so
accessible and it's easy to feel like
part of the family we ate some strange
things but it was all incredible
[Music]
while we loved exploring the city well
outdoor adventure is it hot so we wanted
to get some fresh air and see what the
wilds of the province had to offer the
city is surrounded by wilderness you can
easily get out and play
no matter your skill level or how much
time you have you don't have to go very
far to slow down an experience solitude
[Music]
there are a few places in North America
where you can so easily combine the open
with the wild outdoor adventure with
cultural exploration travel just around
the corner to somewhere that feels so
far yet we found it all in Quebec City
[Music]
[Music]